some rural hospitals are being used to
set up big paydays from insurance
providers raising questions about how
insurance claims are reimbursed since
2010 eighty three struggling rural
hospitals have closed nearly 700 others
are at risk of closing in the next
decade but as CBS News investigation
found some rural hospitals have become
hugely profitable because insurance
providers reimburse them at a much
higher rates Jim Axelrod is here with
how healthcare executives are now
cashing in Jim good morning good morning
buying a struggling rural hospital might
not seem like the best bet for a
business venture but we found these
out-of-the-way hospitals have become
gold mines for enterprising healthcare
executives looking to quietly make a
quick buck on a hilltop in rural North
Georgia Chestatee regional a49 bed
hospital has been operating for more
than 40 years
you know Chestatee and that's where I
was born so it's got a place in your
heart and eyes
Kelly Smallwood worked there for 13
years most recently in the billing
department Chestatee Zoners had been
trying to unload it for more than three
years until the summer of 2016 when a
man from Florida named Aaron Doral
showed up and offered to buy it for
fifteen million dollars and when you
heard that what did you think the number
itself it set off an alarm
why would someone from Florida come up
here and pay fifteen million dollars for
hospital sitting on a hill it just
didn't smell right to smallwood so she
did some research into the new owner
what did you find out he owned a lab in
Florida called reliance laboratories
what else had he done professionally he
was also an attorney have you a friend
or loved one been injured in a serious
car accident medical malpractice slip
and fall or on the job had he ever run a
hospital before no right after the sale
Smallwood says Doral moved part of the
billing operation to Florida and huge
checks from insurance companies started
to roll in some as large as half a
million dollars chesty has never in 13
years I've been there has
never received a check like that from
any insurance company records showed the
money was being paid out for drug
screens toxicology tests on urine
samples collected from all over the
country some of the testing was
conducted at Doral at Reliance in
Sunrise Florida near Fort Lauderdale but
everything was billed through Chestatee
Regional Hospital their reimbursement
rate is a lot higher with our contracts
on a $1,500 claim we would get
reimbursed right at almost $1,000 and if
they were run through the lab do you
have any idea what they would end up
getting nothing extravagant like chesty
would get on their reimbursement
insurance providers reimburse rural
hospitals like Chestatee at much higher
rates to keep health care in those
communities those higher rates are also
making Aaron Doral a lot of money
documents show Darryl's lab made 67
million dollars billing tests through
another rural hospital in graceful
Florida a similar deal Durrell made with
a hospital in Northern California has
generated more than 31 million dollars
in the last eight months and last year
Doral bought two more rural hospitals in
Georgia and Alabama after he bought
Chestatee
Smallwood started getting complaints
from patients I started getting an
influx of calls patients from Georgia
know these patients are not from Georgia
these patients are from all over the
United States Texas Vermont West
Virginia I knew what they were doing
right from the get-go which was what
they were defrauding my insurance
company on the other end of one of those
phone calls was sewing your rival of
Tyler Texas she happens to know a thing
or two about lab tests I've been a lab
tech since I was about 19 years old you
know how this works
oh yes and I also do the labs billing
where I work and I've been doing it for
the past ten years as well in December
2016 Chestatee regional in Georgia
started billing her insurance $2,700 a
pop for drug tests on her son who was in
a rehab in Michigan
I've never been to Georgia's hoo-hah
but all my kids have never been to
Georgia how often you getting these
$2,700 chart almost every other day so
what was the total close to $20,000 just
in the analysis of the urine sample yes
those kinds of bills disturbed Kelly
Smallwood
after months of voicing her concerns to
multiple supervisors she quit
I turned my notice in on March the 19th
of 2017 when I turned my notice in I did
not have a job lined up I had had enough
Kelly wouldn't the easy thing to have
done just kept your mouth shut and just
keep doing work the way you were asked
to do it
rats right and wrong is wrong that's not
how I was raised if you're gonna do
something you need to do it right and
you need to do it truthfully we wanted
to ask Aaron Doral about all this but he
declined multiple requests for an
on-camera interview Jim Axelrod CBS and
declined to speak with us when we showed
up at his lab in South Florida in person
like to ask you a question about
Chestatee hospital mr. Doral as for
Sonya rival after numerous calls to
Chestatee regional the hospital finally
admitted they had no records or test
results for her son let's say you're
sitting halfway across the country
watching this story why should you care
you better care because it's gonna
affect your insurance because next year
all the insurance companies are gonna
look at how much they've lost and how
much they've paid out and they're gonna
adjust your premium to accommodate it
they're not gonna pay for it you're
gonna pay for it
in an email Darrell said all testing at
the rural hospitals you mentioned is
properly built last month anthem sent a
letter to the hospital Durrell
contracted with in California alleging
thirteen million dollars had been
improperly built the hospital disputes
the allegations but has temporarily
suspended the lab program
Kelly Smallwood is one vigilant hospital
workers Jim generally are these kinds of
lab arrangements legal well of course
that depends on whom you
asks so the insurance companies say it's
fraudulent the people running a lab
program say everything is above board
one thing we do know for sure mm-hmm the
amount of disputed claims across the
country 260 million dollars Wow shows
you need to check the paperwork does mr.
Duvall know how to get in touch with you
when he was we certainly made it run you
over but I would think maybe you'd want
to talk to you a little later today he
got some splaining to do very much Jim
thank you very interesting